Today,
we had ordinarily expected Paulos Arnone,
who is the senior partner of
Goldman Sachs to be with us.
And it turns out,
uh,
we are a lower priority than a new merger
deal and we'll have him a month from
today, uh, which gives us
time to pull together a
bunch of, uh, important, uh,
details about the institutional
foundations of capitalism.
And I'm gonna use the term
wealth maximizing law today.
If you think about,
uh,
what courts do and what legislature's,
at any level from new haven to
the congress, the United States,
they set rules which create incentives
and disincentives that affect how people
behave.
And we're going to do four topics today,
but they're all ways
of talking about that.
I'm going to start with the Coase Theorem,
which is not in your reading packet.
Uh, and neither is it
strictly speaking a Theorem,
but it is a foundational set of
concepts that Hernando Desoto,
his book, which we are reading, uh,
is built on to Soto has in
effect taken the Coase Theorem,
which is 60 years back.
And it one Ron coast, a Nobel prize, uh,
about 30 years ago.
Uh,
has taken the Coase theorem and applied
it to reality in a very lively way.
So the Theorem is a good thing
to have in the background.
A second and very briefly,
we're going to look at a law case,
which is actually in the syllabus
for a little later in term,
but I'm going to bring it forward
because this is really a good place to,
to show, uh, it's resolved.
It's a case about whaling
off Cape Cod in the 1980s.
And what's important about it
is not the facts of the case,
but the way the judge reasoned
his decision. A third,
we're going to do a desoto in America,
uh,
which was, uh, the assignment in,
in this book for today's class.
And finally,
we're going to look at some
of the finer grained, uh,
distinctions in the way you can
structure a business organization.
Coase theorem.
It's about this story. This is,
we've all been through, right,
uh,
about
disputed ownership of property.
Now,
um,
I've noticed a pattern here and let's
see if I've got it right or not.
That
you're always in that third
chair from the end of this row.
I think all three of you are always
in this orientation. My ride.
Okay.
And how would it work out if,
let's say Leslie here came a little early
next Wednesday and sat in one of those
three chairs. It would be horrible. Okay.
Now
what would be horrible about it?
You're all coequal he
students in the course,
the chairs so far as I can tell are
identical except that this one is broken.
What's up?
This is sort of
acknowledged my seat.
Okay.
It's acknowledges your seat and the
other two of you would say something very
like that.
Um, you own this one? Yes. Yes.
Okay.
Uh,
so what we have here is an
informal set of property rights.
There isn't a law of any kind,
which refers to these rights,
but they are the folk
way, folk way norms, uh,
of our classroom. Now, if we
press further, let's take,
you have an in, in your college
and your college and that college.
Yeah. Do you live there? Yeah. Okay. Uh,
are there property rights in and around
your entryway and in your suite and so
on?
Are they ones written down by the
Dean's office or by the master?
Are they,
well, I mean, aren't there
some that aren't written down
perhaps?
Well, okay. Can you, I'm
trying to draw you out on this right here.
Uh, he has a quarter of the common and
dedicated to his desk and his children's
studies.
And what would you think of sitting there?
Yeah.
Okay. And Ray, how does it, does your
friend here have any rights or not?
Um, I guess, let's see, before you go in.
I think we're not doing that one this
morning, this afternoon, but it actually,
it's actually very suggestive,
right?
That there is that beneath government,
outside the actions of the state,
there is an enormously intricate
system of informal property,
which governs the way
we actually function.
And that system, a property,
uh, can be good, bad,
or indifferent.
It can be just or unjust.
It can be notoriously inefficient.
And in fact,
if you think about the
failure of socialist regimes,
one important explanation is that the
underlying informal norms about what
people do with their work lives were never
integrated with the planned economies
in an effective way.
Now.
So that's something about formality.
And in formality,
I also have here a watch.
Um,
it says on the top Mavado
um,
it's really very handsome
and I really don't need it.
I'm thinking of selling it.
And does anybody have any,
does anybody need a watch?
You do. You don't. Uh,
what does, uh, what does the standard
Movado watch sell four in a jewelry store?
I actually don't know. I should've done
my homework. I think it's low hundreds
and I'd be willing to part
with this fund for 20 Bucks
who says deal?
I'd be careful.
Is it conceivable that the proper retail
price of this is less than 20 bucks?
Um,
what I,
but remember what I'm trying to
demonstrate here is information asymmetry.
This watch is worth about $8. And, uh,
it's a,
and if I sold it to you,
what I would be doing is
stealing from the manufacturer,
stealing the brand.
And one of the curious things about
watches these days, by the way,
it works fine. Somebody gave it
to me for my birthday as a joke.
Uh, it keeps, as far as
I can tell, perfect time,
possibly better time than a real Mavado.
Uh,
and there's an interesting
problem about watches, right? Uh,
which is better a $9 Casio,
the cheapest imaginable
Casio or a Timex or a Rolex.
Uh,
if the question is keeping good time.
Pardon?
Yeah.
The Rolex is a mechanical movement
of brilliantly designed and executed
mechanical movement.
And it's not as good as an
ordinary electronic watch
doesn't keep time as well.
And yet people are willing to
pay a thousand to one multiples,
uh,
for the social meaning of the brand.
And that means that there's an enormous
market for cheaply made watches,
gray, gray market watches or
even black market watches,
which knock off a brand name,
uh,
and which people,
people sometimes by really
thinking that it's the real deal,
but more often just thinking it's kind
of fun to buy an expensive brand for say
$20.
Well,
the Coase theorem is about
those issues plus the one
where this girl is vexed.
And the one where she's vexed is
that the property rights to that toy.
Our unclearly marked,
I have a granddaughter who has,
um,
who got the boss gene from her mother
and she's a first a kindergartener.
And her first day at school they got out,
they brought,
brought out a little plastic aunt for
the children to learn basic arithmetic
with and they put a pile of them on the,
in the middle of each table.
And then for kids. And, uh,
my granddaughter came home complaining
that the other kids had been mean to her.
And so her mother talked to
the teacher the next day.
And the story was that, uh, the gray,
our grandchild had taken all the aunts
and put them in a pile and then begun
negotiating bilateral agreements
to give some to the other students.
They didn't like that.
Well,
the Coase theorem boiled down
is that if you have three conditions,
clear initial entitlements to property,
and this is what, this is what's
stressed most in the desoto book,
clear entitlements to property,
uh,
a high degree of transparency,
which is what's missing in the
story about the bogus Movado Watch,
uh,
and um,
and low transaction costs.
Uh,
the Nobel Prize in economics
announced, uh, today,
uh, they, they announced two
of them, but one of them, um,
went to Ali Williamson,
formerly a colleague of ours here at Yale,
uh,
for inventing and elaborating a,
the idea of transaction cost
economics and by trends that we have.
We talked a little about
transaction costs here,
about how hard it is to do to
get, get a deal made. You know,
what deal you want to make a but the,
all the red tape that gets in the way,
uh,
makes it very difficult to get there.
And Kostas principle point
is that in that
tiny segment in the middle of the Venn
diagram where these three conditions all
obtain,
we should expect people to reach efficient
allocations of property no matter
what the initial allocation.
Now notice I didn't say,
and he doesn't say fair
or just allocations,
just efficient and efficient in the
sense that people will trade to a point
where there are no further
opportunities to uh,
for mutual gain.
And you get to a so called Paredo
efficient or contract curve outcome.
And I'm going to,
well I don't do this to you very often,
but we're going to do this with a,
uh,
a graphic demonstration.
This an Edgeworth box
I used one once before and it does
anybody in trouble about how an edge worth
box and set up home if you are.
Okay.
So Smith is here,
Voltaire is their Smith gets that
much paper and that quantity of Penn's
Voltaire gets the OP verse quantities.
If we start at the Red Dot,
Voltaire to entitlements are shown by
the blue lines and Smith's by the pink
lines,
uh, Voltaire would prefer anything,
any outcome beyond this indifference
curve going this way away from his,
his point of origin.
And Smith
would prefer anything that way
from the pink indifference curve.
So there is a set of outcomes
which are clearly superior to the,
to the starting point. And
they're in that set, that Lozenge,
uh, in shape. And so
they will trade to that.
And if the,
if we just set it up as this is a rank
order account of what Smith wants and of
what Voltaire wants, yes,
is that set of outcomes
and those two s and the two
diagrams is the same thing.
And ultimately they'll get to an outcome
where the indifference curves are
tangency to one another.
So there's no further gain from trade.
And there will be a whole set of
outcomes that fit that description,
forming the contract curve,
all those points
and the contract curve will be equivalent
to this possibility frontier in the
other style of diagram.
And
so really simple idea.
Uh,
the way to use the Coase
theorem though is backward.
The coach there is boring.
Incidentally,
I was talking to my tas this morning about
the first round of memos and they had
only one complaint that
they were often boring
and not,
not bad,
but there was none of the author's
personality at most of them.
And you've all learned,
I,
you've all learned long sense how to write
papers in college and get good grade,
but you audit just occasionally
put yourself into it.
Don't do it the standard way Josh,
go out on a limb. Now that's especially
true if you don't want to get,
you don't think you need to go to
law school, Med school or an Mba,
but it's,
it's actually,
I remember,
I remember making it all look the exact
same calculations when I was where you
are,
but a little risk taking and writing
actually endears you to those who,
who read the the work and um,
often actually pays off.
An interesting thing about writing after,
after your Ba, uh, taking
risks with your writing,
turns out to be the only
way of getting ahead.
Standard issue writing page up to the BA
n by and large doesn't pay after that.
It's interesting. At any rate, I don't
mean to alarm you about your grades,
but I think, yeah, I think it's
actually worth thinking about.
Um,
I'd mislabeled this.
The top label should read again
versus rich Gannon is spelled g, H,
e n and this is a case about thinking
out the incentives to make people behave
in productive ways.
The story goes as follows
again is a whaler.
Um,
he operates out of
Wellfleet, Massachusetts. Uh,
it is 1881,
and uh,
he spots a fin back whale
and sends the little boats out with
his crew and they harpooned the whale.
Uh, and thin backs are big, uh,
fast aggressive and they
have one further peculiarity.
When you kill them, they sink
to the bottom of the sea. Uh,
virtually all whales float when,
when killed.
And the general rule
of property in whaling
is finders keepers,
losers,
weepers you've all heard of that.
And the, and the specific, uh,
method is that after you kill a whale,
you either lash it to your ship
and tow it to harbor or uh,
or slice it up and processes at sea.
But these boats by and large
weren't big enough for that.
Or you leave it floating and put a
marker on it and the marker is your,
it's your brand.
It's like branding cattle.
And everybody then is compelled by law
to acknowledged that it's your whale.
But the fin back presents a dilemma
because neither of those strategies is
available to the Waler
who kills a fin back.
And what happened to this particular fin
back is that it floated up a day or two
later on the beach near
Wellfleet on Cape Cod.
And a gentleman came along and found
it and conducted a quick auction.
And Ellis Bob Ellis bought the whale and
processed it into a way oil and other
byproducts,
put them on the market and at this again
returned from his voyage and wanted to
swale back.
So he sued Ellis are rich rather,
sorry. Ellis was the guy on
the beach who found it. Uh,
he sued rich, who, who
had processed the oil, uh,
for his money.
And what happened was that the judge
ruled in favor of gay men and reasoned,
well,
let me not tell the whole story.
Let's suppose you are hired as
attorney for the fin back whales,
the fin back whales hire you as a lawyer
and they want to get this case to come
out so that they will be safe
from whaling in the future.
How would they have the
judge decide the case
back?
Okay. Exactly. And why?
Nope, because the risks.
Okay,
perfect.
So the judge reason just as suggested
that only by honoring the relatively
indirect claimed a property
which gun was urging,
could the industry of bag of,
of wailing for whale backs be incented
so that it would go on in the future.
Now
a lot of things we're doing and
thinking about are analogous to that.
Okay.
Structuring incentives so that people
behave in ways which increased the wealth
of society,
uh,
while trying to increase their own wealth.
Uh,
in effect,
creating conditions analogous
to the invisible hand
in Smith is what the judge was doing.
And it's, it's actually,
you should Google it.
It's only three pages long
and just read the opinion, uh,
because it brings out the fundamental
issues that we're trying to deal with now.
Just Soto in America.
MMM.
Desoto talks in the
early parts of the book,
which we read at the opening of term
desoto talks mainly about emerging market
countries
and the jest is that they
are loaded with dead capital.
Okay.
Oh, can somebody help us with
the notion of dead capital?
Here we go.
Live Capitol Service Focus,
purpose out of the House and um,
it's kind of second line to serve
future investment. Okay. Actually
have a legal right over your house.
It can't serve it in the second purpose.
Okay. So the, the house,
so let's,
let's take the chair you own here.
Is it dead Capitol or live capitol?
Well, it's not a lot to me because I
don't own it, but to the university maybe.
Okay. Okay. That's well put. And we,
we will in fact look at the title
to this room in a few minutes.
The,
um,
MMM
desotos idea is that
in an informal system of property,
which has not been integrated with
a governmental system of property,
people have capital,
but it is dead in the sense that it can't
be used for collateral against a loan.
And if it is sold,
there is no way to enforce the contract
on the sale except mafia style.
And Mafia style often doesn't
work out all that well. So
the,
the
chapter we read for today
is about the proposition that the advanced
economies didn't get to having live
capitol all at once.
It came through a long process and
Desoto in this chapter talks through the
informal practices or property which grew
up in a mining camps in California are
in agricultural communities in Iowa
and other Midwestern states in,
uh,
claims to land in a colonial America.
And what I'd like to do is start at
the present and then work our way back.
Uh, this is a property map
of our present neighborhood.
This is an official map
from the,
the place where deeds are capped
at 200 Orange Street in new haven.
And in every community
in the United States,
you will find a set of deeds and a
corresponding set of maps similar to this
one. I'll do sec this and in large
parts of it and so on. As we go.
Uh, you'll find, uh,
these maps are quite ubiquitous.
Now this one has the peculiarity that in
some parts of the city they've drawn in
the buildings and it turns
out that that's there,
that that has happened where there is a
wealthy institution that paid to have it
done familiar to all of us,
uh,
and not where there isn't
a wealthy institution that
would pay to have it done.
The green lines represent property parcels
and all lists is entirely accessible.
If you go, if you Google vision
appraisal, one word, a vision,
a vision appraisal, new haven, uh,
you'll get all these files and you'll
get a photograph of every structure to go
with it.
And here we have a particular parcel that
includes and surrounds this building.
And there's a close up of the
building and we're in the,
you can see
the match there.
And let's look at four,
three properties first and then we'll
look at some more and we'll see how
structures of ownership get built
around the formalized property parcels.
Um,
61 high street is this building?
Anybody know what 64 high street is?
No idea.
What's the small stone?
Small Brownstone building
across the boy skull and bones.
Okay.
In skull and bones.
Turns out for property
purposes to be called the uh,
Russell Trust. And we'll look
at that. And 41 high street.
I was just there.
Uh,
is Starbucks and some
other property above it.
And let's look at,
well I I,
yeah,
10 66 chapel is actually Starbucks.
I was mistaken in what
I said a minute ago.
41 high is the building
right behind Starbucks.
And this is what you
find on the land records.
So this building is parcel
one four one eight eight,
a map to 61,
block two 52.
It has any effective total area.
And this is,
this means places you
could do anything with.
And this would count every,
every square foot of
indoor or outdoor space.
And it totals a little over a hundred
thousand of which 9,259 is heated indoor
space.
Um,
it's asserted value from
the city is 2.6 8 million,
uh, uh, for the land
4.97 for the building,
7.65 all together.
Uh,
and of that 7.65,
7.65 is exempt from taxes in the city.
And that's a point of
interest to the city.
And what I'm trying to do get you to
do is just get into the details of this
stuff and see how interesting it is.
A,
the net value to the city for tax
purposes is zero owner Yale University
now
compare this to 10 66 chapel,
uh,
where the numbers are smaller because the,
the buildings are smaller and,
and they're nowhere near as good.
Um,
the
net taxable value is
half a million dollars.
The owner is something
called Chapel investments,
Llc and Chapel Investments LLC is
owned by people I know the work family,
and they own four parcels over there,
including the one in which Cesar Pelli
has his architectural office and so on.
And it is organized as
a taxable corporation,
a taxable LLC,
which is,
this is a hybrid,
a hybrid form,
which we'll get to at the end of the hour.
Now let's take the value of this building
and the way it looks to Yale and the
city.
Uh,
if we wanted to mark to market
Lindsley Chittenden Hall.
Yeah.
We want to say,
what would this building really shell for
this building and the land in question.
How would we go about that?
Who's got an estimate more
or less than 7.6 $5 million
more?
Who said more? Okay.
Can we get him on mic?
Oh, there we go. Um, why do you think so?
Okay. Is it a bit, it does. It
looks like it's well maintained.
Might buying this have any
resemblance to buying them?
Lobato watch of this description.
Let's suppose I want to run a,
some kind of a commercial
educational institution.
What would this building be worth if
I were suppose I were going to run
something which was aimed at,
uh,
wealthy kids with bad test scores.
Yeah,
I might name it ray college at Yale.
It has a ring to it.
Right?
And the building use that.
That might be the highest
and best use of the building.
Anybody else got a thought
about what? Yes, Thomas.
I am.
Well,
unless I can get it made into a five
o one c three nonprofit corporation,
in which case I might get
away with not paying taxes.
Um,
so any,
any other use anybody can
imagine for this thing?
Oh, come on. Yes,
some ways.
Well,
I mean,
can we think of anything unrelated
to education you could do with this?
Could it be a resort?
Pardon? I making a movie theater.
You'd make it a movie theater. Well,
I gotta tell you,
I think that's a really bad idea.
If you study the current economics
with movie theaters, don't do it.
Uh,
anybody else
renovating and spilling as
an indication of how much
when you're willing to pay for a
mass amount of money, I buy it. That would
give a lot of value. Well, that's right.
And by the way,
is a good reason to think that they're
not going to sell it for any price that
we could even imagine
capturing the value from.
I think that's right. Now, uh,
the other property is probably already
the Starbucks one is probably already
pretty much add highest and best
use and is therefore an interesting.
Now let's think about the properties on
the other end of the block across Chapel
Street, the end, uh,
down towards the new haven green
and there's a large assembly,
there are about 15 parcels down there.
I picked out three,
and
they all look like this.
They all belonged to something
called the chapel company.
Who can make a guess what
the Chapel Company might be?
Well,
I'll tell you yes.
How, how perceptive. Okay,
here's the story.
MMM.
25 years ago, a Yale college
alum named Joel [inaudible],
who is an irascible and brilliant fellow,
Yale Co,
he has the same educational pattern
as Jim Alexander here, Yale College,
Harvard Business School.
MMM.
He bought, it was a slum. All these,
this whole area down here
was a commercial slump.
The buildings were in disrepair.
They were being used for
a very marginal purposes,
and he bought the whole thing up for
not very much and began renovating it.
And the renovation model was small retail,
small retail with quality, um, uh,
residential on the
second and third floors.
And we're talking about places like the
Union league and Claire's Cornucopia and
the Shubert theater and the
Taft hotel. Now, the Taft, uh,
condominium,
uh,
he fixed it all up and
made it really sing.
And one of his precepts was every,
every property should be
leased to somebody who owns
their own business and is
willing to work really
hard at making it work.
So he didn't go after change.
He went after entrepreneurs. Uh,
and the thing really worked beautifully.
But Shavani is one of
these guys who can't.
He's got the spirit of
champagne Schumpeter about him.
You can never leave well enough alone.
So he gets interested in other things
and leverages the new things by taking
further mortgages on all this property.
And then in the 1980 [inaudible],
there is a huge real estate recession
and he loses it all to a federal offense
of the federal government,
buys all the property for very level and
then auctions it off through something
called the RTC and Yale hires a guy named
Joe [inaudible] who was a student of
mine at som at the time this happened.
He now runs all of Disney's
real estate and Fay,
he invented the Chapel Company and
bought all of the ponies property,
uh, on Yale's behalf for
about 25 cents on the dollar.
And Yale was, had the, the
good judgment, in my opinion,
to leave it all functioning as pro as
if it were private commercial property.
And the neighborhood is a
strengthened enormously by that.
Uh, and Yale. Yale does not
make a lot of money at it,
but it indirectly gets a lot of
benefit by having a strong commercial
neighborhood, a budding the campus.
Oh, we're not quite ready for that.
Well, let's, let's not use
the maps, but let's do, um,
let's talk about properties, uh,
further up in the middle of campus.
I'd like you to focus on one 40 high
street and three Oh six York street,
one 40 high street is the Yale law school
and it's taxable value is $42 million.
That's the building,
not the institution.
MMM.
Across York Street is Maurice or
more exactly the Maurice Trust.
What do you think Morrie's is worth?
Well, the tax estimate is
$400,000 and a little bit.
Who would be prepared to
buy Maurice for 400,000?
No takers.
Anybody tempted?
Okay.
Why are we so cautious about Morris?
Pardon?
Why are we cautious about Maurice?
Wow.
It closed its doors on
December 19th last year.
What's wrong with that?
It would about area.
Okay.
Yeah. I mean, it's, it's,
sure. A rundown neighborhood.
You've got the Yale Hall of
Graduate Studies, Morse and stiles.
Okay.
I am at,
I am the chairman of the group
that it in fact owns it and
okay.
I try not to take offense at
the way you guys value it.
Um, we're investing $3 million
in it over the next four months,
and,
um,
we plan to open it and have all of you
clamoring to get through the front door
or the backdoor, which will
be the whiff and poof bar. Um,
now in evaluating it,
you do have to take into account lots
of things that aren't bricks and mortar.
And I'm glad you said what you said,
you're,
you're blaming the neighborhood for what
is in fact a spectacularly mismanaged
business, right? I mean,
did anybody eat and mores last year?
Can you, can we get the mic to
this lady? We're going to do a,
okay.
Okay. On a one to five star
basis, what's the rating
compared to food that costs
about the same thing? Uh,
on the private market
pain, but, um,
a three.
Okay.
The fun part was the singing,
the memorabilia, the cockroaches.
No, I'm kidding. Um,
but the food was notorious,
right? It was really bad.
And how well did they
do with serving drinks?
Horrible.
There was no bar.
The tables down at Morrie's had no bar.
Um,
and it failed partly because
we were very badly managed.
It was managed by 15 Yale Alumni,
not one of whom knew
anything about business.
That's a little harsh,
not one of whom knew anything
about business except for
just being a stockbroker,
which is a pretty abstract business,
right?
There are no cooks in a brokerage house.
The other side of it,
and we will actually do this case
before we're done. The other,
the other side of it was
a highly restrictive labor
union contract with local to
17 of unite here.
And that contract,
um,
doesn't go away when you close the door.
Turns out under Connecticut
Labor Law that the contract,
if you reopen a restaurant there,
you would normally expect,
you would have to honor the contract.
Now it turns out we have a loophole.
It's going to get us a more,
a better deal than that.
But I'll give you an idea of what the,
so what that means is
that given the labor,
while the value of the building is
affected by the existence of the union
contract,
it becomes almost like paint and
the way it adheres to the thing.
And it included a,
for example,
a provision that there should be four
people called cashiers who count the cash
each night.
Um,
only one on duty each night they
rotated. They were all part timers. Uh,
one of them was a full time teacher
at a local high school and they were
required that you were required to pay
them four hours for each appearance.
And each appearance was how much cash do
you think you'd take in these days in a
restaurant of that kind?
None.
There might on a good
night be $100 to count,
but the contract oblige Morrie's to employ
these guys and worse yet to pay them
vacation time.
So we have a high school teacher being
paid five days of vacation time by
Moreish while he is on vacation,
paid vacation from the Branford
school system. That's a deal.
Um,
so analyzing what gets built on
this framework is a little complex.
MMM.
Let's go through the big story in Desoto,
uh,
about za the
informal property systems
in the United States.
Can anybody summarize it
for us in a hundred words?
Got to take her out there.
Are you headed for a taker?
Oh,
okay.
Uh, I'll do it. Um,
the system of property is
built on nation states.
Nation states are the underlying unit
and when you have a frontier society,
which the United States
remained until about 1880,
you have a vast area where
there is effectively no state
or if there is a state,
it is a very weak state with very limited
capacities to enforce any property
system.
And the,
the key green versus Biddle case which
arose in Kentucky asserted the following.
It said, informal property
rights count for nothing,
only formal property rights issued by a
part of the United States government at
either the federal or the
state level count as real.
Uh, this provoked a rebellion
that included violence. Uh,
it also created an enormous inefficiency
because the existing informal system of
property rights based on
preemption and occupation,
so called Tomahawk rights
or cornfield rights.
You occupy the land,
improve the land,
demonstrate that you're making a living
from the land and it becomes yours.
Homesteading was the name for it.
And in 1862,
the homestead act
adopted into federal law,
that system of informal law and made
an integration between the two levels,
the,
the
wealth that was built in
the United States. Uh,
in the, in everything outside
the original east coast colonies,
uh, is built up on that peace
treaty between formal and informal.
The, uh, he does a brilliant job.
Desoto does with the mining camps in
California and with the land claim
associations in the Midwest. And you
can read the details for yourselves.
Uh,
but the gist is that a well
functioning system of property,
we'll have both the formal
and the informal rights, uh,
in sync with one another,
not in tension with one another.
And if we go finally to,
uh,
the finer details of business,
we're done. Now, I'll use this at
the beginning of class on Wednesday.
I'll talk about how Morrie's is
being restructured and you should,
uh,
the case as scheduled for Wednesday is
the one about the mortgage meltdown in
Cleveland, Ohio, and the URL has
been posted on classes. Be Too.